[موسيقى]
بشكل عام ، لا تحتوي السيارات الكهربائية
على ناقل حركة ، وذلك لأن
المحركات الكهربائية لا تحتاج حقًا إلى
تغيير السرعات ، مما يجعلني أشعر بالحزن
لأنني أحب القيادة وأحب
تغيير التروس ، لذلك عندما دعتني شركة تدعى
Jenn Ovations للقيادة
نموذجًا أوليًا لسيارتهم الرياضية الكهربائية
مع ناقل حركة من 7 سرعات ، قلت:
نعم إذا كان جيل GXE يبدو
مألوفًا نوعًا ما لأنه كان في
الأصل شيفروليه كورفيت ولا
يزال لديه ناقل حركة كورفيت
بسبب وضع ناقل الحركة المصمم بعناية من شفروليه.
كان من الأسهل تركه في
Jenn ovation ، وهو مدعوم بمحركين
كهربائيين ينتجان 800 حصان ،
ووفقًا للشركة ، تبلغ
سرعتها القصوى أكثر من 220 ميلًا في الساعة وهذا
النوع من السيارات المزججة المنحنية
رائعة جدًا لدى
Jenna Batian  نجحت في إعادة إنشاء
متعة تبديل التروس في سيارة كهربائية
، كما يساعد ناقل الحركة في
منح السيارة هذه السرعة القصوى
الفاحشة إذا كنت  لا تهتم بالقيادة في المدرسة القديمة
ولكنك لا تزال تحب قوة
وأسلوب كورفيت حتى لا تقلق من
الأجيال المتوفرة مع
ناقل حركة أوتوماتيكي بـ 8 سرعات - أو فقط ضع
الدليل في الترس الثالث وقيادته مثل
أي سيارة كهربائية أخرى إذا كنت  إنك
تقليدي ممن يستمتعون
بإثارة القيادة ولكنهم يريدون الفوائد البيئية
من التحول إلى الكهرباء ، وعليك
أن تدفع نقرة ، فالجنرال يطيع شينجي تكلف تكنولوجيا المعلومات
سبعمائة وخمسين ألف
دولار وهذا يبدو كثيرًا مقابل ما
هو معدل بعد كل شيء  من الرياضة أنهم
يصنعون فقط خمسة وسبعين من هذه
السيارات ، لذا في الوقت الحالي ، على الأقل ، فإن شحن المعدات الكهربائية
مخصص فقط لعدد قليل من المشترين المحظوظين
، فلنأمل أن تنتشر